who told you this name is
oh that's his name you didn't give him
that name
I think he eats from the back where's
the zipper right here yeah you can make
him eat from the back take open the
zipper and then make him eat him haha
is that a good idea
yeah okay
pull it down
eyes
he eats from the back
there you go yeah stuff them in there
not a monkey Cheeto don't eat our monkey
shut up
monkey Cheeto by the way is a dog chew
toy but it's taika's best friend yeah
yeah and monkey Cheeto goes through the
ringer every single day taika puts like
chair legs on his stomach like monkey
Cheeto deserves it but you love him even
though you abuse him right yeah
good morning good morning okay okay
let's go check on the other monkey
you want to say good morning good
morning good morning oh he's so nice he
said good morning back
okay while that's happening
we got the other freaking monkey Cheeto
over here
is that too bright
good morning papa how you feeling today
is it better I just have a headache
because I think I've been taking
caffeine for the last couple days oh so
it's a caffeine headache not a sick
headache yeah I feel way better though
like 90 probably I'd be 100 tomorrow oh
yeah because tomorrow we're doing
our matches
no what's his name again Huggy wuggy ate
your monkeys
oh yeah his cousins bought it while his
tea and Thea bought it for him at the OC
Fair I think
oh
no
your monkey Cheeto is gone forever
where's Cooper
's in the cats
arms yeah oh Cooper's the octopus can
you show me who Cooper is
of course of course
what
I gotta go I'm gonna be late
this is Cooper this is Cooper
oh
no Cooper get off of his face
okay monkey I gotta go I love you guys I
love you bye
in yesterday's Vlog I was talking so
much [ __ ] about California
in like a cutesy way okay I [ __ ] love
California I'm a Kelly at heart tell the
girl at a heart I'm never gonna not love
California but this right here cannot be
replicated look at how gorgeous this is
it's not smog
it's a cloud and it's so beautiful
right now I'm in traffic again at
[ __ ] eight in the morning on a
[ __ ] Saturday okay I'm not
gonna go on that
um but I am on my way to touch these
black ass Roots up
um some on my way to my hair appointment
I have found my perfect
hair stylist and I refuse to like go
over it took me years to find her I do
not give a [ __ ] that I have to drive
into another state
to accomplish this to work with her
because it's that difficult to find
someone
that understands my style understands my
hair has enough Trend knowledge to give
to achieve the [ __ ] wonky looks I
always want
um that has enough hair knowledge to be
the most up-to-date when it comes to
just different hair technology and all
that stuff so yeah I've done plenty of
[ __ ] on my hair to know when it's
when the person's really good or really
[ __ ] bad and I found someone that's
really good for my hair so I don't care
that I have to wait forever to see her I
will see her
um and also I love this hairstyle
because unfortunately
um I have the gene where I have a lot of
gray hair like a lot of gray
specifically in the front here like you
can kind of see it there but this
hairstyle covers it up so nicely when I
had my pink hairstyle it was just the
ends or like midpoint that was all
highlighted blonde and then colored to
whatever desired color color I wanted I
had a big pink so as soon as these roots
started growing out more you can see my
white hairs right off the bat
immediately within two weeks I needed to
dye my hair again and I just don't like
the white hair look maybe when I get
older and I feel like it's time I'll let
it all grow out and I'll just have white
hair and I think I'll be completely cool
with it because I'm just gonna look cute
as [ __ ] but it's not time yet I don't
want it I'm not ready for it
so until then I think I have found my
perfect hair color to hide it so if
you're someone like me who gets a lot of
gray hairs here and you're relatively
young or at least you don't like it
kyung has nothing to do with it
um then I would highly suggest getting
this style because it's so fun it's like
been my favorite hairstyle okay I
probably say that about all my
hairstyles but this one for sure is by
far one of my favoritists
um what is going on over here there's
just a lot of [ __ ] happening has been my
favorite hairstyle so I'm keeping it it
hides my grays it's trendy it's cute I
can do a lot with it my hair is damaged
as [ __ ] absolutely yes
um
but it's okay
it's okay it looks cute and it's
actually no it's actually pretty damaged
it's pretty bad
um but it's okay it's cute it's just
here it'll go back whatever if I have to
go bald you know me I can't wait to go
bald I'll go about
okay I better start driving again
I mean I've been driving but I better
focus on driving
okay I'm just awkward now I'm just gonna
keep it on it just got it just got weird
I made it weird didn't I
have arrived safely in one piece this is
my salon
Lux it's going it's so cute
make your appointments here with Rianne
just three and I don't know anyone else
I'm done this is always the weird part
for me because I have like no roots like
I just feel like it's just straight
scalp color
um so this is not my favorite day one is
not my favorite of when my hair
goes back to no roots
um just because it just looks so weird
and I look so dead and pale and I feel
like I really need makeup on my face so
I do like it once it's been like a week
of growth that's like my favorite and
then when it's a few uh when it's
probably like
um
this last time I waited nine weeks which
is really bad for the growth so that's
how you might see some like yellow up
here
but usually I want to get in around six
weeks
um and even by the sixth week Mark it
still looks so [ __ ] cool so I love
when I get black
black roots so right now I'm kind of
like but I'm not complaining because I
really needed it covered up all the
Grays you can't even tell I love it
I'm annoying myself anyway in other news
Bart
got a nail in his tire and we're dealing
with
a low
PSI right now
and I don't know if I should drive it
back home it's about a 30 minute drive
from the city to the to my mom City
but [ __ ] it I'm gonna wing it I'm just
gonna go slow but yeah there's a [ __ ]
nail in his tire and he's got beefy
tires so
it was like the perfect
the perfect timing the fact that it
pierced his [ __ ] tire it sucks
must be a big ass nail how big is this
[ __ ] nail
I have all sorts of questions
okay so it's not safe to drive so I'm
still in the city of Glendora like five
minutes away from where I got my hair
done at American
entire deeper
yeah so gonna get it patched up Papa
Bear's on his way to rescue me
um I should have probably done like a
triple A type of deal but I don't know I
don't know does AAA patch [ __ ] up I
don't know I feel like they're just
gonna put a spare and then I go by
[ __ ] detail I don't know I don't want
to deal with it I just want to drop it
off and get rid of all my problems and
not see until someone else fixes them
I'm just there y'all I'm [ __ ] tired
I'm so tired so yeah I'm here on the
corner like a hooker waiting for my
husband to pick me up and hopefully no
one else at the bigger [ __ ] uh wad of
money picks me up before him because
I'll [ __ ] go with him I'm just tired
of working
kidding all right Jokes Aside I'm not
gonna be a hooker
I wouldn't make it in the industry
um
but my face is blurry why
there we go so I found a Starbucks
where's it at there it is fan of
Starbucks
um it's gonna take part like three
minutes to get here so in that time I'm
going to get some work done because I
work a lot but enjoy the work and this
right here is literally me cutting
weights moving for the past two weeks
finally closing on that
um having a son that gets random
seizures
I'm just so tired oh and we just drove
in from Nevada to California to drop my
mom off so so thank you my coffee is
ready to give me life be right back so I
got a little tall
um cold brew I try not to drink my
calories so
um I just stick with black I know I
could do like a splash of this and a
[ __ ] sugar-free that but I don't have
to I'm not gonna it's not the best
flavor I actually don't even really like
drinking Starbucks but I really need it
and that's all they have out here
um besides all these like donut spot
Yummy Cafe [ __ ] places that have like
look at that spot
I'm sure they're gonna have way better
coffee
but you know what else they're gonna
have
[ __ ] donuts and Temptation and me
going
my heartbreaking so I'd rather not do
that to myself right now
um I told BART to come get me because
it's gonna be about two three hours in
there and jack [ __ ] to do in Glendora so
I'm like uh I'm not gonna wait here for
that long and I also was like he hasn't
replied but I'm like hey do you want to
just come over here and like we can have
like a little breakfast day just me and
you because we haven't had a long time
in a long time so I'm like let's just
have a [ __ ] date on here so let's see
what he says I know he's gonna be like
I'm so down
so
um yeah I'm kind of nervous I think I'm
about to go on a date but I don't know
he hasn't replied to me yet
I think my date's here
oh my God how embarrassing the door's
locked
hi
you received your Prince Charming's here
Prince Charming with the broken Chariot
why
because you're tired there's these
California streets man I know they're so
[ __ ] dirty they're just so full of
haters but the haters I'm so surprised
that pierced you're tired that big right
did you see the picture yeah you sent it
to me I saw let me see I don't I
couldn't get it I couldn't get a good
angle but look at that
look at that
what'd you go tell them to do just to
patch it patch it up yep yeah yeah then
we're gonna change the tire just gotta
patch it yeah I just said I gotta know
my talking you guys Tire can you guys
patch it up that's Kimmy what do you
think of my hair I love it
it's candy on you thanks so you don't
want me to go bald I showed Bart this
picture of me going balding I was trying
to look you're still hot but no no no I
was trying to make myself look sexier
and I was like come on man
come on man and I was like uh I better
stop because this is ridiculous but
would you go Bots though come on now
what do you think
no
what do you hope what do you think
yeah okay well hey you didn't answer my
question what was your question do you
want to go on a goddamn date you [ __ ]
loser yes where are we going where are
you gonna take me you better pay not on
our joint card
okay well surprise me okay
fine
it's been an update so my knight in
shining armor came to pick me up
I'm driving now
they couldn't fix his tire
um I guess the tire size to the
equipment that they have they just can't
do it so now we're off to go take it
somewhere else they were able to patch
it up so at least it's in drivable
condition but not for like a really long
time
um so we were in Glendora now we're
gonna go all the way to Monterey Park
um
yeah so probably no date today
how does this happen how did this happen
at least one thing is I'm gonna get my
mom some flowers I got it from the
vendors that are you know off to the
side of like a freeway entrance
or exit
um and my mom's always giving those guys
money because she's like man like that
sucks they gotta stand in the Sun and
you know they're working really hard and
stuff so she's always like my mom's the
[ __ ] best like when I say my mom's
the best my mom is the [ __ ] best and
yes she's better than your mom I'm just
kidding your mom's probably a [ __ ]
badass too
um all moms rock man
um I didn't even consider myself a mom
when I said that but yeah we all rock
um so yeah got her some flowers
feeling under the weather a little bit I
think I think she's so tired I feel so
bad like I wore her ass out
because it's been a crazy
two and a half three weeks and prior to
that we were in California for the month
so like she dealt with taika for a long
time and Tyga is a handful y'all he's a
[ __ ]
hand [ __ ] fool so yeah I think
my mom is just so tired luckily we leave
tomorrow and we let her
we let her relax and stuff so hopefully
these flowers will bring a little smirk
to her tired face
my poor Mama I'm so sorry okay so Papa's
driving his truck I'm driving my mom's
car say hi babe
hello no say it no I'm not recording
your truck just say hi Oh so we're on a
phone conversation right now and the
phone covers oh there he is
and the reason why we're having a phone
conversation is because we saw a UFC
poster and now we're talking about the
fight that's coming up between uh Diaz
and how to say his last name kamza
Samaya yeah
um so
yeah tell me what you're gonna say
so what I was going to say is uh there's
a fighter named uh I believe Greg Hardy
or Dan Hardy I forgot I'm getting names
mixed up and his last name's Hardy yep
and he thinks which is crazy because
this is just outright disrespect oh but
he thinks no one is better
no no he goes why would Dana White
approve a straight out assassination
uh against Diaz yeah
yeah that's what he's saying which means
that's complete and utter disrespect
because he's saying that Diaz is
completely helpless in this situation
and there's nothing he can do yeah
that's what it sounds like
but this is our romantic talks uh we we
talk about we talk about UFC and we call
each other like yeah our new Builder is
calling me after after okay okay okay
bye okay goodbye
um yeah we're [ __ ] cute and we're
also [ __ ] weird but that's what makes
it work we stay true to ourselves
and that's this is romance for us it's
[ __ ] cute I just I was like oh my God
are we really calling each other right
now and talking about the UFC and I'm
like I gotta document this I gotta put
this on the record
yeah
he's over there
I'm over here
and uh yeah we're [ __ ] in traffic
still we're still in a goddamn traffic
California
I [ __ ] miss California no I don't I
really don't
and again I don't want to hate on it but
the traffic bro the [ __ ] traffic
oh there's an accident on the other lane
what the [ __ ]
it's on the other side
okay we've safely made it
to
our actual go-to tire shop at Monterey
Park none of these are sponsored or
plugged or any of that I just want to
share some really cool spots for you but
we always always always always come here
especially when we lived out here we
come to Grand Prix they have super
competitive pricing
um the customer service is amazing it's
top tier they know what they're talking
about we know that we're gonna get uh
Quality Service here so
here we are now Papa I have to drop him
off to go get a haircut
whoops
so maybe no date today no date
whatsoever okay let me go drop you off
okay
so what started off as such a CUNY day
where I was about to have a CUNY date
with my husband turned into a date where
I didn't get to eat my first meal until
about 7 30 8 P.M
how this happened
I don't know but that's life right
I'm not complaining because I got to eat
so much and so many snacks
let me just let you know what this meal
was about today because that [ __ ] was
so bomb
to me at least it's one that's on a cut
so you may not believe me this is Texas
medicine but I had all this
in one sitting okay let me tell you what
I had for my main course
I had some ground turkey 99.1 and I did
this on purpose because I wanted to keep
my fats low so that I could eat more of
the yumminess so I had this I paired it
with this
and that was really bomb so that was the
main course then I took it to oh then I
wanted to get because I was so behind my
protein I needed about 100
70 grams of protein this right here was
about
75 80 grams
um a protein I had two scoops and I use
and I love our barbell Brigade
um protein because it's zero carb zero
fat with 25 grams per scoop so I had two
scoops of this bad boy and I drank it
with well no I didn't I didn't I tried
it with water I was about to say milk
but I didn't because I saved
the milk
Fair life
zero fat six carbs 13 protein and paired
it with a cup of [ __ ] cinnamon
[ __ ] toast [ __ ] Crunch
and I'm so sorry if you have children
that are watching this mine is right
there so same same yes so once I was
done with this I was like oh I almost
forgot I paired this here too this here
too this year too because it has
20 grams of protein 4.5 fat only four
carbs so this was here I'm so sorry then
I went here you're still with me and
then I went here after here
I went with
this
this was so goddamn mom
then
I had two of these bad boys
each one with one tablespoon of the
super chunk
Skippy and this is just all fats oh
protein carb carb
protein
carb
protein protein
and I had six of these and it was
amazing
and that's how I closed out
so good
yeah that's one of the reasons why I
actually like tracking Macos because
it's very scientific
um and it's all a numbers game at this
point right especially if you're on a
cut you want to be on a deficit but it's
really cool because
you can
you have numbers to work with to see
what it is and how creative you can get
to keep what you want to eat obviously
some things you're just not going to be
able to fit in your Macros but a lot of
things like what I just showed you you
can so um if macros is something that
you're very interested in I highly
highly highly highly recommend getting
together with the coach
um so that you can see what it's all
about
um it's also called flexible dieting
because it's very flexible
um and as you can see it works I've been
on it since we started the get lean
program that's the program that I'm
currently running
um it's our barbell Brigade program that
is meant for people that want to get
lean but want to feel capable and super
athletic
um all well still maintaining strength
because obviously we are barbell Brigade
we're centered around the barbell so
strength is always going to be at the
heart of anything that we do
um so definitely check out that program
because that's what I've been running
for the past uh 10 going on 11 weeks now
um and I've seen amazing results you've
seen my results I've been getting super
shredded super strong
um and yeah you can't you can't really
achieve your goals unless you do your
own research or you get with people that
know a lot about that specific thing and
us here at barbell we know how to make
killer [ __ ] programs killer
supplements killer attire
um so yeah go on Barbara brigade.com get
yourself some protein get out some subs
my
favorite pre-workout is obviously made
by us as well so check out our
pre-workout because
with having a kid
that's what inspired the best
formula for pre-workout so to all my
parents out there that want to train but
don't have the energy get our
pre-workout it's going to wake you the F
up
um yeah follow the program get with the
coach that can help you you know track
your nutrition and and help you
um
um get on Macros because
I am mad at it I'm mad at cutting
because cutting is never fun but I'm not
mad at the results that I'm seeing and
I'm not mad at the food that I get to
fit into these numbers so
you know you win some you lose some and
right now I still feel like I'm on a
constant win with all that being said I
will let you go
say good night
have you say goodnight to my family who
uh my husband's watching
the UFC oh my God it's about to be Usman
I'm about to watch that my CUNY CUNY
wuni Sun Sun he's eating some dumplings
I'm watching kids YouTube
and I'm so doubtful I'm gonna lay down
because
I'm about to
explode thank you so much for watching
see you guys